the king off but it wasn't really doing
too much if you cut the king
um gives the track he's gonna bring his
rook back okay yeah this is good
okay so raj above he didn't have time to
go and win one of black's pawns because
actually black's king would have gone
across two versus one on just
one same side he's a dead draw um so
you need white needed if you wanted to
win to win both of black spawns on the
left side but there just wasn't time to
win both of them that's why he's gone
back to the defense
of his other pawn but now yeah the
king's kind of come forward now
this does it's not enough yeah the
problem is black's rook is active
attacking white's pawn and controlling
the other side
white's rook purely passive defending a
pawn look at rajabov's face
he knows he's blowing it he let the wind
slip
and magnus this is why he's so good in
the end game end game expert
not only does he grind out small
advantages into wins he gets
difficult positions and saves those
draws yeah no i mean this is just
technical
excellence and they've actually agreed a
result draw
there it is it is a draw in game three
between these